je veux fabuleux officiel javier mas
chapeau m'échapper messieurs
[Musique]
il m'envoie
quoi que
du lait
[Musique]
tout s'accélère
c'est pour ça que je t'aime ligne et
d'une paire curan qui nous a pour la
première fois en 45 ans de carrière un
album compilation jim corcoran toujours
originales à l'esprit fin souvent très
drôles et l'on peut constater tout seul
même album album compilation
effectivement pour la première fois en
carrière et ce sont ses albums solo
qu'on a retenue dont huit albums qui ont
été lancées depuis le début des années
90 on a laissé de côté pour l'instant sa
musique folk des années 70 avec le duo
jamie bertras il ya des chansons qui
serait moins connus qui ont tourné plus
de 25 mille fois la radio qui ont été
intronisés au panthéon des classiques de
la cinq ans la société des auteurs
compositeurs et éditeurs de musique des
chansons moins connues qui est jim
corcoran en plus d'avoir toutes ces
belles qualités il est on a est aussi il
avoue que l'exercice de la compilation
ne l'intéressait pas du tout mais si le
président fondateur des disques
audiogram michel bélanger son complice
de la première heure qui lui a dit je
m'en occupe
j'ai dit monsieur je comprends ou juste
des best of et de cd compilation ça ne
m'intéresse pas je trouve ça trop
mercantile tout se trouve paresseux et
bida on fait un calcul de ce qui est
connu moins connus qui ont fait jamais
transport initiale au dj je montre que
je dis ok c'est un projet michel alors
michel à écouter tout ce que j'ai fait
depuis 1981 et c'est lui qui a fait le
document c'est lui qui fait un
documentaire mais de ce que j'ai fait
selon ses goûts selon ses préférences
ce que j'ai fait qu'il ya touché michel
donc vu que quelqu'un s'en occuper
c'était correct pour lui il a fait une
semaine riche en émotions pour lui le
lancement de cet album là également il a
été décoré de l'ordre des francophones
d'amérique
oui organisée par le conseil supérieur
de la langue française d'une cérémonie
qui a eu lieu mercredi dernier à québec
en présence de la ministre de la culture
du québec nathalie roy donc le
clairement mérité parce que le non
seulement choisi de créer en français
pendant toute sa vie mais il a présenté
les chansons francophones canadiennes
aux canadiens anglais pendant 30 ans par
son émission de radio à propos diffusés
sur les ondes de cibl ici la radio
anglaise de radio-canada et pendant son
allocution et bien il a eu quelques mots
pour cinq ans par ma grand mère
maternelle était québécoise francophone
elle s'appelait henriette lépine mon
grand-père h libéraux
ma grand mère ne mourra jamais entendu
ni parler ni chanter en français elle
rougirait de bonheur aujourd'hui de voir
son petit fils honoré de cette façon par
l'ordre des francophones d'amérique être
considéré comme francophones me semble
que c'est un petit peu plus que
francophile c'est un francophile c'est
un pas dans la bonne direction et
maintenant avec l'ordre des francophones
je suis considéré a fait est dorénavant
comme francophones d'amérique saint bris
du tarn et je suis ravi vous savez
manifestation encore en lui il est mis à
sherbrooke il le fait des études aux
états unis visite une secondaire et
universitaire et lorsqu'il est revenu à
sherbrooke
il explique qu'il fallait qu'il fasse un
choix est ce que j'ai plutôt mis ma vie
en français ou en anglais et ce qu'il
expliquait à la télé de radio canada en
1987 c'est en partie grâce à bernard de
rome qu'il a appris le français
quand survenus au québec
les caps et anglophones que je
connaissais début des années 60 mais je
les avais perdu de vue donc j'avais le
choix du milieu dans lequel je voulais
vivre et je trouvais que ce qui se
passait au québec dans un et 60 début 70
c'était très très animée surtout du côté
francophone alors j'ai plongé
j'ai décidé d'apprendre la langue
française et parmi les tâches que je me
donne n'était pas une tare superman
c'est d'écouter bernard de rang et
d'enregistrer même et puis de faire
autant après pour comparer les accents
pour avoir peut-être un peu d'accent
radio canadienne et parce que j'aimais
le fait que je comprenais tout ce que
dans leur disais et je vais donc
demander à celui qui consiste cet album
compilation qui est maintenant
disponible à michel bélanger quelle est
la chanson pour laquelle vous vous
seriez bat reçus pour qu'elle se
retrouve sur ces compilations là c'est
un de ses plus grands succès perdu dans
le même décor en voici quelques secondes
tu pars tu viens d'avant temps
pas et
on s'est perdu dans la mer
médina le même décor
[Musique]
et
des cas
je